oh that part's too good that's
distracting right oh that's a lot of you
hate this okay
configure assaults BTS sweet sweet BTS
wow this is way better so thank you to
those of you that I feared having an
issue with that setup because my
insecurity about you being upset with
that setup has caused me to be happier
with this now setup hi my name is grace
helbig if you did not know now you know
your life is different now I don't claim
that it's for the better but it is
different oh I will be very upfront with
you guys I am exhausted
my brain is delirious and I am also
tired but I wanted to post a video for
today cuz I've been very not good at my
video schedule this is a
stream-of-consciousness video if you are
new to my channel or to me as a person
sometimes I shoot
stream-of-consciousness videos which are
just a random smattering of
stream-of-consciousness thoughts that I
have in my brain
lazy videoing some might say profound
conversations starting others might say
it's the first one I didn't do my hair
makeup like this someone else did my
hair makeup like this because I was
shooting podcasts all day today which by
the way if you don't know my dog is
having a WWE match with a rawhide bone
apparently downstairs best of luck to
you use the chair podcast yes I have a
podcast called not too deep which has
relaunched itself on the fullscreen
platform so you can watch full episodes
of the podcast on the fullscreen
platform we've had so many amazing
guests so far this like season whatever
you want to call it at it we just this
relaunch has had a lot of really really
amazing guests you can also get a week
free if you go to fullscreen calm / not
too deep you get a week free on the
platform so you can go binge watch as
much as you want on there yeah trap
Queen right that's what they say that's
that is that what that means all the
episodes are available on iTunes and
SoundCloud to listen to for free the
week after they released and a bunch of
already available over there so go check
them out uh they've been really fun
podcasting is stupid fun I just I get
really tired after it but here's the fun
thing I get super tired and then I can't
fall asleep or I fall asleep for like
three hours in my brains ik cool we have
enough gas in our tank to keep going
I can't stay asleep what makes you stay
asleep just drinking coffee and red ball
day like not contribute to a good
night's sleep
don't answer that what else is going on
in the world oh it sucks that's what's
happening actually here's something
interesting
I probably shouldn't talk about this in
this state of delirium but you know
there's no time like the present
KC nice tat acclaimed vlogger filmmaker
extraordinaire who I'm a huge fan of
posted a video the other day in which
she just spelled out that he is voting
for Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton I
will be voting for Hillary Clinton and
he highly encouraged other big
influencers to let their audiences know
who they're voting for because this is a
very important election it's oh it makes
my heart ache I don't even know like I
wish I knew I wish I knew how did that
tequila
I wish I knew the right way to talk
about this and there is no right way um
there's the left way ha ha ha
partisan joke Oh get good guy
Casey's video is really interesting to
me because there have been obviously a
very a variety of opinions expressed
about Casey's video Phil DeFranco made
another video about Casey's video in
which she was disappointed that Casey
seemed like he was forcing like mob
mentality sort of thing on other content
creators to express their opinions then
the thing that annoyed myself and many
other people is then Casey takes it to
this place so if your favorite youtuber
says things like I don't like to talk
politics on my channel or I'm not going
to reveal who I'm voting for call them
out it was at this moment in my opinion
Casey Neistat released a hate mop my
opinion is I will be voting for Hillary
Clinton this election Donald Trump is so
many things that I don't want as a
representative of the country that I
live in to the rest of the world it's
like when you do a group project in
school and you and certain members of
the group work really really hard on
your group project and then that one so
that wasn't ever there that was doing
their own thing besides that they're
going to present your group project to
the rest of the class because they think
that they can get by on certain charisma
that they have and instead of presenting
all the hard work that you did to make
your project rate they just talk about
themselves the entire time and then also
somehow talk about your weight for some
weird reason in the middle of it but
then go back talking about themselves
and it's all that work that you and your
group put in to make the project as best
as it could be he's just like ruined by
this person that doesn't care that your
grade on that project effected your
future yeah that's like Donald Trump for
me
and I don't want that person presenting
the United States of America to the rest
of the world that's my opinion
and you are so welcome to have your own
opinions I'm not a news outlet so I'm
allowed to have a biased opinion on
YouTube I just encourage you to find out
for yourself what you value that's
ultimately what this election comes down
to in a lot of ways is where your values
lie so many people say Hillary is a
criminal Donald Trump is also a crime
like he's also a criminal whoever is
elected to be President of the United
States will be president for four years
four years this election season has been
happening I don't know a year I have
lost all sense of time it's been a very
minimal amount of time in comparison to
how long the person we elect to be
President of the United States will
actually act as president of the United
States so that's something to consider
I've talked so long about this let's
talk about some other stuff this is not
the most exciting video I know and if
this is the first video that you see of
me grace Helbig I apologize this is not
what I'm like all the time I'm just
[Music]
Haggard I feel a little Haggard but like
in a cool fun way I always the haters
back off premiere last night for calling
balancers new show it's the Miranda
sings Netflix show it is so good I've
been a Miranda fan for seven years now
memory and I first saw Colleen
performance Miranda sings in a show
called the rejection show it used to be
in New York six seven years ago and we
were all in it was such a great great
performance and so it's amazing to see
now this like Netflix scripted series
and kollene works so hard and the show
is so funny and all of the other actors
and actresses in the show are so funny
and I just think you guys will really
really like it so get ready I don't know
when that comes out because time is an
illusion and I am delusional what else
is going on oh I had tortilla chips for
dinner let's just see in Twitter moments
what's been happening
this is all sad all sad it turns out
news is really sad
I'm deflated literally I'm usually one
of those freshing carwash new store
blow-up guys that's all over the place
and now it's like someone just turned
the Airstream off and I'm just a sad
deflated version of that which is
probably the saddest image of then Trump
being elected president of the United
States of America and that's it thank
you guys for watching this video if you
liked it at all let me know in some way
shape or form give this video a thumbs
up leave me a comment down below or
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because it's not always tired but when
it's tired its tired I don't know if
you're one of those people that still
doesn't know exactly how to register to
vote and you think it's complicated and
you feel weird about it so you just
don't look into it please go to hang out
vote such grace helbig it is the easiest
way to check your registration and/or
register to vote in your area and it's
all through text message which I know
you know how to do because you're here
right now on the internet and that's a
feat in and of itself please please
please register to vote and please vote
it is really important this year tired
grace thinks it's very very important